so Susie tell me tell me your story
you're
you grew up where in Beverly Hills
Beverly Hills in the flats so not
the north side
um but we have a nice you know house my
dad had a business
um he's a manufacturer of schwanta like
things for the home
you know
um
let's see my parents passed away both of
them
um this was just about 10 to 15 between
the both of them
um and let me start how I did the Heidi
thing we'll get to that okay so how
would you describe your childhood in
general
I was I had everything I needed of
course I didn't think so then but I was
more than
what kind of what kind of girl were you
in high school I was a bad kid I went to
continue Beverly Hills High School
continuation oh really yeah so what
attracted are you the black people I
smoked a lot of weed are you the black
sheep of your family yes
what What attracted you to the the
darker side of things I've always been
attracted to the darker side of things
it's always been something that I'll see
first
I don't know why and where did that lead
you
here here
in Skid Row yeah but before you came to
Skid Row you did some other interesting
things you told me um yeah well you know
in the beginning I was just an alcoholic
you know and I stopped smoking weed when
I around the time I started to do money
you know creating sex for money I met
Matt and Alex first and she turned me
down she says no she's too Madonna at
the time I looked a lot like Madonna
um everyone said so I didn't think so
um and she liked it more like a suit you
know but then Heidi did what she did how
do you slice yeah she took Matt and
Alex's
phone stuff
and ripped off all her clients
so she told me about and the sky should
I leave the same Anonymous yes
definitely please yeah yeah
um and um he peed on me and I ran out of
there okay you can tell me
he was into like what was it his name
was
his dad was a huge he's a huge Asian
okay one of the biggest ones
um his dad discovered Marilyn Monroe
okay
um I think uh yeah you must know him
probably or anyone in the business would
know them
um he had girls in and out Playmates
Penthouse like really beautiful girls he
liked boobs you know
um
so I ran out of there then I I was drunk
one night I came back from a club he was
leaving leave me messages like I'll give
you a thousand reasons why you should
come over he looked a little bit like uh
David Letterman
and he has Coke all over his nose and he
was on the verge of like a stroke
because he talked talk like like that
you know
um I was always worried about him and
there was some of the girls that were
Shady you know that I would be looking
around like I see okay you know
um the girl one of the girls I brought
this girl Michelle she worked for time
life she wasn't very attractive but
I told him I'll come only if she could
go so he accepted
and you know pay a thousand dollars just
to do nothing her I have to do all the
work
like sit on his lap and be like hey
Daddy and you'd be like tell me about
all the [__] things you've done
I'd be like okay and I wasn't really
good at making a lie up like that you
know
um
I mean I could but I the Integrity of
our exchange I always wanted something
about my integrity and the dark side is
weird because they don't care right
um yeah so
Jonathan yeah so it led me to other men
too there was other men that I'd go to
one time I was blowing Jonathan and I
had lipstick on when I walked out we
were still you know trying to find the
keys and stuff and she ran out and she
goes oh my God Jonathan has AIDS yet
blood all over his dick and I was
thinking oh my gosh I was too uh
perplexed to even say no no no it was me
yeah she's like
you know because I didn't want to say it
was me I mean it was embarrassing I was
really embarrassed about what that was
in in the beginning anyway
so um her sister Shauna oh yeah she was
in a horrible car
um I remember how do you sister yeah
Shawna with more of my my age
um she got in a horrible car accident in
the Jeep with some Heidi
and she I don't know she just said she's
wild you know she's just a wild girl
and then that thing happened with the
court and everything I didn't get she
was super cool for not involving me
because this involved the end with what
all that would happen in court did it
involve his prostitutes I really had
nothing to do with prostitutes it was
taxes and stuff like that I think what
was your impression of Heidi after work
you worked with her for how long I liked
her a lot how many years did you work
for there oh I knew her some small CBC
uh like 30 years ago and uh it was for
like 15 years when you each other her
dad was a pediatrician
um Paul I think is his name she comes
from a really good family like I do she
treated you well really well
really well I know she treated a lot of
people like [__]
but she couldn't do that to me because I
came from um a social background that
you know it wouldn't have been she liked
me
we were both in the same kind of
took on the same cloth yeah kinda kinda
so she was I don't know maybe she could
have been me but she wasn't
um and lifestyle worked for you for 15
years you were happy doing it I wasn't
happy ever doing it because it's I feel
sorry for the men it's like what do you
guys got you know is it a real but men
are different you know they're like I
get what I want I don't want to have
conversation and reality and all that I
just want to have sex and I wanted to be
so I finally got that
you know where I was in such a what was
it the hooker with the golden heart or
something I think the men are getting
what they want
yeah well you know I I I like men a lot
I mean even if they're like gay I I look
at them as huge
you know what I mean I still believe men
if she got what they want that's great
it's a great attitude yeah there's so
many people that hate men or hate women
or hate whatever
understand
I love women too but I mean I'm just
saying I think men
like I said I don't care where they're
there
are first in line women and then
children
what are we going to do if we're stuck
here alone without you guys are we going
to be able to build you know
hardly oh we all need each other yeah I
wouldn't say I wouldn't put men above
women I would just say they were all
worthy of kindness and love oh that's
true yeah that's definitely true
I don't I don't use race or
sex or anything like that to separate
that's right because the other side of
the coin
yeah there's always the other side each
other
that's the story thank you for that
um you started it you started it so what
do you so that led to where what did you
do after after Heidi then I got involved
in heroin it was the 90s that was a bad
move
we're using drugs when you were doing
the prostitution thing
um no I you I have you had to be really
like perfect Heidi's girls were clean
yeah
all of us maybe they made money
yeah well a lot of them did blow
um I I
just think I just I think I just did an
interview with somebody where I said
nobody in the game is making money but I
think
Heidi's girls hiding Heidi's girls
probably made money uh
what would you charge for a session I
will only charge a thousand dollars for
like 20 minutes
because that's all it took that was 30
years ago yeah it's a lot of money
yeah it was pretty good A lot of girls
were making more
um those are the girls that she you know
zeroed in on after I was exited a
thousand dollars just like spend like an
hour with a dude
oh an hour with a dude yeah it never it
never took that long
yeah I guess you're right um maybe 15
minutes half hour yeah half an hour 15
minutes a thousand dollars for that yeah
and sometimes you'd be waiting for the
him to finish with a girl that he he
couldn't ejaculate he was he was
ejaculated with me twice the blow didn't
allow him to oh yeah drugs and I felt so
bad you know but how do you girls were
the the finest of the fine right yeah
they were all very clean and you know
but in the end things started getting
weird like
you know the blow I'm sure and fights
and Alex singing and then getting busted
and then everyone turning their backs on
everybody and backstabbing and getting
actors involved yeah that was horrible I
wasn't around by that time I had already
had a decline and I pushed out of the
way so you you left that lifestyle and
picked up I didn't think it was worthy
to go to a guy strung out on heroin
being that all you want is money money
money money money and you like you know
let me get out of here
you know it wasn't it wasn't gonna work
I in my mind I thought it was like
you're crazy you got these crazy ideas I
did
so heroin tell me about that
um I moved to Seattle in the 90s with
all that you know
um I had a boyfriend
um I knew a lot of people in bands and
stuff
um
that was like my scene
um I started hanging out with like the
rock like at the cat house and
stuff like that
um it was Heavy Metal at the time when
when this all started and then moved to
grunge
um Seattle I came home because I want to
go home and all of a sudden
I just weird stuff sort of happening to
me with the drugs and and the Coke and I
started doing more crack and the
paranoia and this is going on and that's
going on I never went back to Seattle
so I just um
gradually my parents have let go and put
me in rehab and all that stuff I refuse
to go
um but I got a case which is when you
get busted by and thank gosh Proposition
36 had just come through otherwise I
would have been doing three years in
prison for that one time
it was really strict before you know so
um yeah I I got all of that I started
going in and out of rehabs first it was
promises and places like that in Malibu
and then I just got to County places
and then ended up
um
being homeless you know
because I lived with the sky for a long
time he was bad news
for my parents you know and so I I
stayed away from home and I became
homeless
how long you been homeless
um chronically for like
10 years
and are you still yeah I live at the
lion guard yeah so you technically have
a roof over your head low see you're
probably be able to come here well
probably not no but I've interviewed
plenty of people to stay at the at the
wine cart yeah yeah that's a big housing
unit for people there's a straight fresh
out of prison or right or in your
situation yeah
so now I'm kind of building myself up I
don't do heroin I'm on methadone
fentanyl didn't come into the picture
for you
um methadone came in the picture about
Fentanyl
oh fentanyl I I did that in all three
days ago and I was like
you know this isn't very enjoyable I was
looking down like this I couldn't even
open my eyes I was like
oh no I'm going to go back on track here
no I would stay away from that yeah
so everything's been flying since and
the methadone is helping you it really
helps it's probably the best thing that
helps it kills the craving kills the
craving completely even for Fentanyl
I just didn't want to do it but now
you're addicted to the yeah I'm addicted
to that but at least it's not like oh no
it's three in the morning I'm sick and I
gotta run out and you know do something
crazy to get some money
there's worse things to be addicted to
yeah I'm not a thief type so it's like
I wouldn't I'm not good at like did you
get a job now on methadone
I probably could yeah
but I don't know who would want to hire
me since I haven't been employed for
a big stretch of time
well I mean you know if it comes it
comes that would be great how are you
surviving though
um on SSI I'm on Social Security it's
not very much I'm really poor
do you have kids I I have a daughter
named Delilah
she's really wonderful so cute
she's 16 17 now did you raise her I had
her for two years and then I had a
leather go in the system because I was
on drugs methadone and I was still doing
like Coke or and stuff like that
you talked to her
um I talked to her through a door
because she's I'm I don't want to scare
her me looking like this she's not used
to she looks fine you know it's scary to
see your mom go from because I was
living with my brother in Vegas and her
and I went from you know like a total
mom 24 hours a day
than when I lost her I got so upset it
wasn't that I started doing extra drugs
it was just that I was homeless I didn't
care anymore
I got the fuckets have you but you look
great
oh you're so nice thank you I wouldn't
picture you as like when you first when
I first met you I was like I don't think
you're a good fit for what I do but
maybe you're interesting and sure enough
you are but I would not have picked you
to be homeless on Skid Row right yeah
the lifestyle you were leading with
Heidi that's that's fascinating to me
what what was your impression of that
because you did it on a very high level
she got really dark what did you learn
about men
from doing that
um
that they can be victims to
I mean they're treated like by these
girls
not very well I mean it was interesting
what you said earlier that you felt
sorry for the men
yeah even though most women would be
like or most people not on this end
well not in this end no yeah here the
women are taking advantage of like
on an hourly basis I mean but things
were happening like you know um one of
my friends like she wasn't she was we
went to same school she was a little
older so in in in that in Beverly Hills
it was like your class you know I don't
know why you hung out only with people
your age
so she was a little older so she was
friends with my friend Pam and Tracy and
um these girls ended up in
Paris locked in yeah I walked in a hotel
they got locked away in the hotel and
their passports taken they had to climb
out the window with no clothes on I mean
it was crazy so things did happen dude
I wouldn't I wouldn't have done that you
know a lot of the Arabs would come they
were very nice to me
you know
um Heidi though was
the coke I think is what was really
doing it
setting the scene for a very destructive
is the back and forth I guess it was
coke but the drugs are what unraveled
that whole thing I really believe that
let's gotta go drugs have a way of
unraveling a person's life it's just
interesting the thing about Coke though
no it's like like the uppers especially
like Crystal math or crack what does it
do it gives you energy it makes you a
little bit sharper seems to make you a
little bit better version of yourself
right
but somehow it well it does yeah
everybody nobody escapes nobody's exempt
yeah unbelievable but you know who knows
what they were put and there's other
things we don't know about who's putting
blood in the cup so now you have to
worry about her Fentanyl and stuff like
that yeah
but back then it was probably much
better cocaine oh yeah
I remember when she had that house and
she had helicopters flying over it and
she was horrible she came she she's
unraveled I mean she's not the same girl
I I knew my friend Bob Forrest did a
show on TV so about rehab or something I
would love to interview Heidi oh yeah
oh you would really love that
should I try to do something yeah
somebody should yeah I've actually tried
before but she has not returned my see
but she she's kind of like Primadonna
now because she's so like she's own a
home can't blame her she doesn't want
and her babies are her Birds she's in
right can't leave her Bird yeah yeah but
I can come to Vegas I can come to
Pahrump yeah I'm sure but uh but you got
to you have to honor the fact that
somebody might want their privacy now
they don't want to be in the Limelight
they don't want to be would you would
you put it in the paper or something no
no I I have a YouTube channel
and it would be on YouTube so oh you
have an interview Channel that's great
yeah that's what I do for interview
magazine
no I just have a YouTube channel that's
amazing
and but you don't put People Like Us in
there do you yeah all the time wow did
you let the snow we're gonna be on yeah
that's you're gonna be on
really what do we get for being on I
guess I'm gonna pay you right now and
we're done oh that's wonderful yeah
that's what I do that's wonderful yeah a
lot of people like hearing these stories
of of all kinds of different people from
all different walks of life I find it
Well I'm gonna start writing down my
stories
you probably have a book in in you yeah
really like a lot of people I've
interviewed do yeah I shouldn't use
names though you should not use names I
always take them out oh good like the
name that you mentioned earlier I'll
take it out thank you so much you're so
honorable and I'm just a I'm just a dude
trying to do the right thing great
you're great Susie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you you're
fascinating if I write down some other
things could I come back and sure if you
have more you want to share okay I'll
start writing down because I have so
many stories
it's just that right now I'm only doing
like
this is what happened then this would
happen then yeah you're a certain mode
so maybe with a little bit of time you
can on Earth some of the other ones yeah
I'd be open to having you back
okay
yeah all right darling well thank you
very much thank you so much